ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de pannes
il est toujours loin de ceux qui vivent
leur vie ensemble assez pris à ce qu'on
voit la foule
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ces français ne veulent plus
de prisons des choses à dire la france
oubliée c'est une rencontre avec ses
citoyens il ne se résigne pas à la
fatalité la france oublié ses montées ce
qu'on ne voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends à chazelles sur
lyon dans le département de la loire
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour gaëtan et bien on est
devant votre établissement le lycée des
horizons oui vous allez nous expliquer
tout ça vous avez vous présenté déjà je
suis professeur d'histoire géographie et
de spécialités en lice et j'ai des
classes de seconde première et terminale
et j'enseigne depuis deux ans dans ce
joli lycées de zones rurales alors on
est où là exactement
alors nous sommes à chazelles sur lyon
qui est une petite commune qui se trouve
à l'ouest des monts du lyonnais
dans le département de la loire mais
deux kilomètres du rhône vous êtes
professeur d'histoire géographie
vous enseignez aussi d'autres matières
l'enseignement moral et civique et la
spécialité histoire géographie sciences
politiques et géopolitiques et forcément
vous avez été très atteint par ce qui
est arrivé à samuel pattes il ya
quelques semaines
à titre personnel oui très atteints j'y
pense encore
j'ai eu du mal à reprendre et ça a été
difficile encore aujourd'hui de gérer
émotionnellement et professionnellement
cette situation tragique effectivement
vous êtes dit ça aurait pu m'arriver
complètement sa alimenté le sentiment
d'insécurité que je développais déjà au
sein de l'institution
je me sens quand même pas pas protégés
par mon employeur et je sais au fond de
moi que ce qui est arrivé à samuel pâtit
peut arriver à beaucoup de collègues et
que je pense pas qu'on aura là le
nous la sécurité qu'il faut la
protection pare donc il faut l'émotion
est un petit peu retombée on en sait un
peu plus sur les circonstances sur
l'absence de soutien de sa hiérarchie et
l'absence même de soutien du corps
professoral la culture dans l'éducation
nationale repose quand même sur un pas
de vagues et que effectivement il ya un
système de promotion qui repose un petit
peu sur le fait qu' on ne fasse pas trop
remonter les faits dans les
établissements pour le dire un peu plus
clairement si vous êtes chef
d'établissement et que vous voulez
obtenir un établissement plus important
est donc une rémunération meilleur il
vaut mieux qu'on entende pas trop parler
vous et ça peut expliquer pourquoi
certains chefs d'établissement confond
parents d'élèves et clients est-ce que
vous vous sentez abandonné est-ce que ça
participe de votre peur au quotidien de
votre à sécurité au quotidien qu'elle
soit physique on l'a vu bien sûr mais
aussi peut-être avant tout psychologique
moi je me sens pas abandonné
je me sens réduit je pense que quand
j'ai débuté ce métier on était
considérés comme des experts des experts
notre discipline
bien sûr il fallait toujours discuter
avec les parents expliquer comment on
procédait les objectifs qu on
poursuivait mais on avait une certaine
latitude dans notre classe qui elle par
contre été sanctuarisés
j'ai l'impression qu'avec les dernières
réformes qui sont survenus on a cherché
à transformer le professeur expert en
professeur technicien est aujourd'hui le
sentiment que j'ai peut-être subjectif
c'est que le professeur devient une
sorte de courroie de transmission un
organe qui permet de faire exécuter la
doctrine qui émane de la hiérarchie
voire de la très haute hiérarchie étant
fonctionnaire j'ai pas en débattre
je dois faire ce qu'on me dit de faire
c'est certain mais je pense que ça nuit
beaucoup à l'autorité et au crédit du
professeur c'est certain et en tout cas
ça alimente aussi le sentiment
d'insécurité que je peux
or puisque aujourd'hui n'importe qui
peut se permettre de remettre en
question ce que je fais sans même en
avoir l' expertise
je viens pas au lycée en ayant en tête
que l'éducation nationale se soumet je
viens plutôt au lycée en ayant en tête
que lundi que l'éducation nationale est
de plus en plus instrumentalisée par le
pouvoir politique et qu'on demande à
l'éducation nationale un peu de remédier
à tous les problèmes de la société
aujourd'hui vous diriez que vous êtes un
professeur heureux épanoui
ou plutôt amer à un bonheur d'exercer ce
métier est effectivement une angoisse
oui une angoisse de ce qu'il va devenir
je devrais peut-être pas dire les choses
comme ça mais j'espère quitter ce métier
avant qu'ils soient complètement
détruits ou dénaturer
je peux vous inviter à boire un café
chez ma mère si vous voulez allons-y
allons chez maman
[Musique]
le voit l'arrivée on est où là
alors nous sommes à saint etienne le
molard le la demeure d'honoré d'urfé un
grand romancier poète du 16e siècle il
reprendre le café chez ma mère voilà
allez c'est parti donc là vous venez
régulièrement
oui il m'arrive régulièrement sortant du
lycée de temps en temps de venir voir
mes parents et j'ai l'habitude de boire
un café avec ma mère et de discuter un
petit peu c'est n'est vraiment pas loin
et bien soyez les bienvenus bonjour
et voilà je vous présente ma mère lui a
chanté
bon je vous remercie nous accueillir ça
va faire du bien parce qu'il fait un peu
frisquet et là vous disiez tout à
l'heure
j'espère finir avant que le métier soit
devenu trop difficile
c'est terrible comme constat je risque
d'être un peu cynique mais j'ai
l'impression que aujourd'hui depuis même
plusieurs années
l'idéologie qui triomphe c'est celle du
profit et de la rentabilité
et je pense que tout ce qui ne n'est pas
ne rapporte pas ou n'a pas une
rentabilité immédiate et jugé futile ou
ou inintéressant est-ce que tout
simplement entre l'institution
les pouvoirs publics et les
fonctionnaires notamment les enseignants
n'est pas tout simplement un problème de
confiance aujourd'hui effectivement tout
vient du haut tout est vertical tout est
très centralisé
on dirait que l'administration centrale
a peur finalement que que on n'applique
pas véritablement les réformes comme
comme il faudrait vous avez le posant la
république qui rentre là dans la maison
de votre maman dit ben attia je suis là
pour vous écouter alors c'est pas la
convention climat
ne sais tu pas le grand débat non plus
qu'est ce que vous lui diriez je
demanderai à ce que monsieur le ministre
quitte cette administration
c'est mon voeu le plus cher on souffre
beaucoup
c'est très difficile et ça devient
pesant et dans un deuxième temps
j'aimerais qu'on remette en place un
climat de confiance entre les familles
et les professeurs et cette confiance
elle ne se décrète pas dans des lois
elle se construit sur le terrain avec le
temps et entre les relations qui se
tissent entre les différents acteurs de
la communauté éducative sans être dans
la dystopie vous avez déjà imaginer
votre métier dans 20 ans je suis sûr que
oui dans 20 ans mon métier encore plus
mal payés qu'aujourd'hui encore plus mal
traités qu'aujourd'hui
et pourtant c'est déjà pas mal
et quelque chose qui s'éloigne un peu
des missions premières qui étaient
d'instruire les élèves de les éveiller à
des savoirs en fonction de discipline et
en faire des personnes curieuses et
critique capable d'évoluer dans le monde
et de devenir des vrais citoyens qui
défendent les valeurs de la république
merci gheit en pagaille temps vous savez
on conclut l'émission toujours par une
photo vous allez enlever votre masque
d'accord et puis ça m'a donné la petite
idée là vous allez sonner la cloche
puisque on l'a entendu tout à l'heure
vous avez sonné le tocsin de l'éducation
nationale
[Musique]